you
songwriters are here producing a pop
number Benjamin Buddha's releasing it on
the Dutch market as an independent label
he needs a good sense of what music
people will be listening to and when and
he has to hold his own against the big
players
what's his concept you create a classic
song and afterwards or even beforehand
you think about what direction you can
produce it for in my case I have a very
strong emphasis on electronic music
you've always been that way at first we
kind of laughed at you you and your
electronic music you were on it really
early you spotted right where the music
trends were heading right and I just
started making lots of contacts in
America and here too with European
artists and DJ projects Benjamin Buda
experiments with different approaches
he's invited songwriters to compose hits
for stars like uh der Lindenberg the
publishing house in Berlin the family
business is nearly 70 years old and has
subsidiaries the world over and many
awards their pride is the gold for
Alphaville who they've been working with
for over 30 years with more to come that
was the very first award I got it was
for the album and single by Ivy Quino
she'd won the first series of the voice
of Germany before that we flew to
America and held a songwriting camp with
some composers Benjamin's father Ralph
Buda takes care of the older stars he
appreciates legends such as Elvis
Presley and Bill Withers
his grandfather landed the rights to
their music long ago singers are still
covering their hits today in generating
revenues for the publisher
they say they cannot return the change
to the next generation is very different
from what I experienced exactly my
father died when I was taking my final
high school exams so there was no
handover now I'm overjoyed to be working
together with my son and helping him
along of course when you're working in a
creative capacity you're taking risks
Benjamin Buddha and his team checkers
and new demo he signed up almost 50
songwriters to date starting in a family
business isn't as easy as just walking
through the door it's always terrifying
to start out as a son or daughter in a
family business the employees generally
don't make it easy for you and I was no
exception I had to be extremely careful
about what changes I wanted to make how
much I'd shake up and how much I just
take on as was some of the employees
here had worked for my grandfather
Alvaro Soler is a singer and songwriter
and Benjamin Buda is his manager here
they discuss upcoming concerts but has
even teamed him up with Jennifer Lopez
for his summer hits
what's good about Benny is that he's
very young but he's already got lots of
contacts and he's got no problem at all
talking to someone who's a really big
name that's also pretty cool
koi Berg is the district in Brennan with
the highest concentration of music
club's venneman Buddha takes in dozens
of concerts looking for the right acts
for his label his criteria are very
clear
thus bring the what do the performers or
composers bring to the table without our
help and what can we bring in and
because that's the part we're interested
in sometimes it's absolutely perfect the
way it is and that's good too but we
listen very closely to see where we
might be able to help with the lyrics
and polishing the music up maybe in
collaboration with other songwriters
coming up to enablement under-15 on a
brilliant band called fly cat fly is
playing in a club they're hoping to make
their big breakthrough with their new
album venneman buddha is looking for a
particular sound and he's got plenty to
choose from but berlin's clubs are
teeming with undiscovered talent
you